[Music]
i regret that he wasn't able to get
kedarius tony by the way that's rare
today's speed round brought to you by
verizon yeah that is rare i like the
candor if i'm travis atn the guy who was
drafted at number 25 instead of cadarius
tony i'd wonder i'd wonder where the
coach is going with all of this uh
i'm the guy you got i'm sorry if you
wanted somebody else maybe it motivates
travis atn to be better than he would be
all right and that is what urban meyer
uh did he would have drafted aries tony
if available at number 25. if i'm the
giants i'm a little bit like hey this is
our guy now you don't we don't need you
to be
coveting our property thank you very
much we have them under contract or we
eventually will
hands off eyes off don't talk about our
guy no i i mean you know
they're gonna like it actually the
giants are gonna like the fact that he's
talking because it's going to make them
look better with that number 20 pig i
think travis atn he'll he'll he'll be
all right he'll get over it i mean yeah
they still picked him at 25 that's
special but yeah i think you see there
with like see that's where you you get a
little look behind the curtain with
urban meyer he came from florida he
knows dan mullen i'm sure dan mullins
told them some special things about
cadarius tony and then of course you're
watching the film too
they probably thought oh you know we
we're going to get him at 25. we like
this so that hurt him i i appreciate you
know the honesty of that situation all
together i really do uh if nothing else
this guy in number eight will feel
better because look at him when he hears
cadarius tony what the hell
well urban meyer wanted him dude so hey
guys be happy urban really wanted him so
he's going to be special for you guys
and we'll see hey this is another as i
said thursday night another reason that
there are no excuses for daniel jones
this year they have loaded up the cannon
with weapons yes they have jones and
he either becomes josh allen this year
or he doesn't i think that's kind of
what they're trying to set up isn't it
they want him to become josh allen
they're they're definitely going all in
on just weapons and they're gonna go
wait we think you can sit in the pocket
and pick people apart you know they got
they got all the talent you need when
you talk about the running back the
tight end and evan ingram gallaudet
you know slayton
now kedarius tony and now it's just
about can daniel jones and jason garrett
come together in that spot there and
really formulate a really good offense
that can scare people schematically to
go along with that talent but yeah i
mean this at the very least
you know we know the giants are all in
on daniel jones and all of that but the
the thing that this will really force
though it's gonna give them the answer
that's the good thing yeah it's a make
or break year okay we're giving you all
the chance to succeed if he can't
succeed or do something like somewhat
special or good with this group like
you're saying then they're gonna have
some answers at the end of the year to
know exactly what daniel jones is and i
think that'll that'll be good for them
ultimately too
daniel jones obviously was not the
rookie of the year when he was drafted
in 2019 way too early guess for this
year's offensive rookie of the year
chris the odds are already out from
points beth yeah i i you know
i'm i'm intrigued by like kyle pitts
who's not on there i mean we know the
quarterback's dominating there oh he's
farther down he's farther down right
okay
but
he's right there tied with mac jones i
believe so but though they're
interesting i i got to sit here though
and
it's hard for me to say justin fields i
got to see that bear's offense and how
they use him and all of those issues i i
think trevor lawrence would be the guy i
would i would go with right now i would
again like
jacksonville if we had a longer for
eight o'clock segment there there
another team
that won the draft i mean they did a
phenomenal job they just got so many
difference makers and guys that are
going to contribute to their football
team and you know they had a pretty good
offense set up
uh for trevor lawrence to begin with and
now you give him atn uh and of course
the defense is gonna be better but i
think i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna go with
trevor lawrence i'm gonna go with the
number one pick right now
you know the mvp award typically is a
quarterback prize rookie of the year it
depends more on stats yes
i i i given the odds right i'm always
looking for the value and i i like nadia
harris at plus 1400 he wasn't on that
graphic he's not one of the top guys
yeah but the steelers running back yeah
if they're going to use them the way i
think they're going to use him right
he's going to get the touches he's going
to gain the yards he's going to score
the touchdowns and he's playing for a
team with enough cash see that's a
problem
jaguars are trying to get cachet
but
they they've got a ways to go to get
true cachet the steelers have cache out
the yang yang baby so playing for them
plug and play with juju smith schuster
ben roethlisberger the defense they have
i think najee harris has an opportunity
to make somebody very happy at 14 to 1
odds yeah i don't disagree with that
you're right he's going to get the ball
a lot and and and both
honestly mike
i thought about taking travis atn for
some of the reasons you kind of just
said just too because i think it's
they're going to have that college
spread type offense and he's got alvin
kamara type ability to where i just
think he's he's going to have amazing
statistics i'd be shocked if he didn't
either so uh yeah but
atn's plus 2 000 by the way plus 2 000.
okay yeah not not 20 to 1 odds not not a
bad bet either uh but they still have
james robinson i know yes and here's the
thing if that offense takes off this
year and atn does well and lawrence does
well it's going to be like 2016 cowboys
dak prescott was the rookie of the year
right over his eagle right the
quarterback's going to get the the bump
if that's what happens uh defensive
rookie of the year way too early guess
for that chris oh well i mean this one's
easy like i love michael parsons but the
second guy there on the list is the one
i'm looking at jalen phillips what
you get to be
a top five pick
and you ended up on the 18th team who
already has talent and other good
players on the front seven
and you're gonna be coming off the edge
for the miami dolphins and that team
with brian flores as creative as he is
at exposing like blocking schemes i mean
we saw that last year he went through
like a five-week stretch where offensive
coordinators couldn't pick up their
blitz
nobody could he was basically just going
here we're gonna line them up all here
you don't know and we're gonna screw
with you i mean i just i think jalen
phillips is definitely the guy i'm going
with
i think i'm i'm uh intrigued by a couple
of them jeremiah wilson
who felt around two the browns traded up
the browns were thinking about taking
him in round one yeah he's got the
chance to be a tackling machine in that
defense and with defensive rookie of the
year i went back and looked over the the
years that there is no rhyme or reason
to it it's driven by stats it's driven
by tackles if you're a linebacker sacks
if you're an edge rusher interceptions
if you're a defensive back and saks plus
overall sense of f the play up like in
aaron donald in 2014
uh gregory rousseau is the one that i
like twenty to one i like that uh just
because
he's it's a good team he's gonna have
chances to rush the passer a lot of
points right and i think he's gonna be
pretty damn good all right last one zach
wilson top button swag oh baby i knew i
liked this kid i knew it and i listen i
like what they did in the draft too the
jets are another team that killed it and
i just got to see him and mike lafleur
and everything go first before i could
pick him to be the rookie of the year
we'll be back with our monday draft
right after this
pro football talk is brought to you by
verizon built right for business
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports